on today's show we talk about some heavy
heavy themes this is not a show for kids
we're gonna be talking to a young woman
who's feels responsible for her broken
relationship with her mom
and we talk through what she can do
about it we talked to a young man who is
moving away for the first time
and he's not so young and we talked to a
wife who's trying to
recover after her husband's suicide
attempt stay tuned
hey good folks i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone show
show for you by you about you
you're walking through life trying to
figure out what to do next with your
parents
with your kids with your loved ones with
that special somebody
that looks at you gives you butterflies
in your stomach
or just gives you a like a roaring
headache man we are here to walk with
you
on the show we talk about falling in
love we talk about falling out of love
we talk about
loss family insu
no not family inches actually we talk
about family issues
we talk about i don't know hope
sadness we talk about people who are
freaking out man and thinking that
we're pretty soon going to be trading
dog food and
guns and coffee
for water it's probably not probably not
i want to talk for a second about
where we're just coming from and that is
black friday
some of you are sitting at home right
now curled up under a blanket
wondering why you have a headache it's
because you caught covet
you caught covets storming the walmarts
for eight dollars off
a blender or getting in line with
i don't know like uh clubs and
and chains trying to beat your way
through to get the two for one special
on hot dogs or whatever it was your
black friday shopping
and now some of you keyboard warriors
are listening to the podcast hoping to
get some inspiration
right before cyber monday
it's all time it sounds like terminator
5 right i don't know how many
terminators are there four of them
it's like terminator 5 cyber monday i'm
gonna click my way to happiness and joy
and 11 off a big tv
so good job everybody i am i'm not golf
clapping you i've actually been
practicing my collapse
and um i'm gonna i'm gonna regular clap
you
good job cyber monday folks here's what
i want you to do i want you to
cyber monday over and buy me and all my
friends books
here at daveramsey.com buy all of our
books because we do have a pretty dope
uh cyber monday sale and then close your
computer
close it listen buy all of our books
nothing says i love you
nothing says merry christmas like a book
about mental health issues
that's why i'm your guy i got you man 10
bucks you can look like you're caring
and you're being a little snarky and you
are
thinking about their future and hope and
you're making a statement for 10 bucks
that's incredible so go over to
daveramsey.com
uh cyber monday sale buy all the books
and then close it
and then go out and be with your friends
dude i wasn't even planning on pitching
that man that sounded awesome
i should be a salesman for a living i'm
the worst salesman
james terrible but whatever's going on
in your heart at home
or head close your computer go outside
and see it or give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693
or you can go to johndaloni.com show
we got a new way of emailing into the
show johndaloney.com
show we got a form there makes it easy
for you to fill out makes it easy for us
to get your information and call you
back
johndaloni.com show looking forward to
it all right let's go straight to the
phones let's go to chris
in san antonio texas chris what's going
on
hi john how are you i am doing
outstanding how are you
i'm good thank you thanks for taking my
call thank you for calling what's up
sure um so my question today is
how can i deal with or better handle
a difficult relationship with my mom for
several years we have been
disconnected and most of that time not
even speaking
my parents divorced in 2015.
it was real nasty and real bitter time
for all of us
since then the relationship between me
and my mom has dissolved
i feel guilty for not having her in my
life but i'm scared or unmotivated to
try again to build a relationship with
her
after so many years of confusion and
anger
i'm still searching for the chapter and
the book that tells me what to do
next i don't know how to set down the
toxic relationship
and also set down the guilt from letting
her go from my life
well thank you for your trust in there
that's a lot um so take me back to this
divorce
why did she end up on the
the bum end of the divorce is it her
fault sure
um no i i wouldn't say
you know either of them's fault but the
tension between
us certainly started appearing in the
years leading up to that divorce
um she was she was seeing other men and
she would openly
talk to me about that and while she was
still married to your dad
yes oh wow that puts you in a wacky
situation man that sucks i'm sorry
how old were you oh
i was 20 when all of that started that's
terrible man i'm so
sorry so um she's just openly cheating
on your dad
and is he a good guy is he he had fault
in this thing too
no his their good guy
no no no no he is i was saying no to the
fault i say the disconnection with them
unfortunately they chose a difficult
lifestyle he was over the road truck
driver my whole childhood my whole life
okay so their their disconnect started
with just after years and years of him
being home one weekend
a month you know i could you just of
course that leads to bad things in a
marriage and they drifted apart
and so um this divorce here is in 2015
you said yes
so five years go by are you not are you
talking to mom you're not talking to mom
you're avoiding her
she reaches out and you just ignore her
text tell me what that relationship's
like
we had chapters so it was in 2015
when divorce is happening it was
finalized christmas of 2015.
so that year we didn't speak much but
she was dating somebody
and she was dating that person all of
2016 so we didn't talk
much because i didn't i didn't care for
the person i didn't care to be around
the person
she lives five hours for me so for me to
visit with her would go to see her and i
didn't want to see her in that person
why didn't she come visit you she
i really don't know in 2016 i'm not sure
i think she was busy with the new
the new guy um so i took a couple
opportunities to go see her but like i
say not often because i didn't want to
be around him
right and then in 2017 it really broke
down because my dad
still lived in that city and he was in a
very very dark place like a
life or death situation and i saw the
flags
and i jumped on it and i brought him
here to san antonio
to live with me to live with me and my
fiance at the time
wow um to help him get on his feet he
needed to be surrounded by
positivity and support so when i did
that
she called me out said i was choosing
him
i was supporting him she would not come
here to the to san antonio while he
lived in san antonio
and that she she would straight you know
very clearly say i'm angry at you
for coming to get him and babying him
and doing this for him
he should have figured it out on his own
so your mom is really immature huh
yes like borderline brat
yeah grown-up brat yes
yeah immaturity is a good adjective yeah
okay
so anybody who cares for anyone
and is told you're choosing them over me
that that person doesn't get a vote in
your life anymore that's nonsense it's
just immaturity
right that's just what a what a brat
okay so i don't talk bad about your mom
uh too much so bring me to now why do
you have this
this hole in your heart that you think
your mom is going to fill
right well so the final so we
i still i tried like i say i felt like
it was in chapters so then that chapter
kind of came to an
end and she came back around and we
started talking again in like 2018.
in 2019 i got married to my fiance
and that was the end of another chapter
because she did not support
the wedding because we weren't going to
have people there we just went to a jp
and did our own thing in austin
and again she's immature and even your
wedding is all about her right so
yeah god almighty all right so we didn't
speak again
a few months went by and so the final
thing was the end of last year
she reached out again after months not
speaking and said i want to see you
i want to come to san antonio and see
you and i'm like wow
seven years i've been here you know i
didn't say that but i'm thinking like
seven years i'm so excited so i was
everything nice
positive you know absolutely i will
spend the time with you whenever you
want to come
so she chose the weekend and she drove
the five hours here and i met her at a
gas station on 35
just so she could follow me to my house
and she had never been to san antonio
so she got to the gas station parked
walked across the lot
screaming at me as she was walking
across the parking lot
that she couldn't do this she couldn't
be around me she deserved better
i was just going to treat her like my
dad treated her
and she was a human and she didn't
deserve
to be treated so poorly and got in her
car
and left and i presume drove the five
hours back home
and we have not spoken since and that
was 14 months ago
i don't know what's in your soul right
now that you thought
i still have an obligation to this
relationship
i i think because just the common line
you know when well how does your mom and
i say well we don't
speak anymore and the response to that
is always
it's your mom you should work it out if
you only have one mother
you should you should get over it and
call her
and make this right so i want to i want
to free you from that
chris you can't make this right
um your mom's
i would even go past immature now that
i've got this other piece
of information i think your mom's very
mature but it sounds like your mom's not
well
and she probably hasn't been well for a
long time and
you are a prop for your mom
you are something that she you are
someone
and i'm going to tell you some harsh
stuff okay you are somebody in her life
that she leans up against when she needs
to blame why she is where she's at
you are somebody in her life that she
probably
talks good about when she needs a
self-esteem boost in
an area with people that she associates
with five hours away wherever that is
and you are somebody that she has
created a fantasy about
with some thumbs up and some thumbs down
and you can't
be responsible for how she responds to
you
and the hardest thing you're going to
have to come to terms with
is the that and you've heard me say this
the fantasy of you and your mom
is over right it's not going to be what
your friends have
and it's not going to be what you
desperately wish it would be
and the sooner you can wrap your head
around who she truly is
and who she actually is and
she is somebody who will
berate their daughter for saving her
dad's life
she is somebody who will drive across
the country
to yell in person about how awful
somebody is and then turn on drive back
right she is still your mom your friends
are right she is
and then any any stretch of the
imagination
reaching out and making that right is is
the right thing to do
unfortunately for you you're not in that
situation because that connection takes
two people and you are dealing with
somebody who cannot receive
connection and so you could reach out
you could try to reconnect and it will
always be on
her terms and you will always be the
beneficiary beneficiary of whatever
bricks she's choosing to throw that day
and here's what really sucks do you have
any kids yet
i do not okay is that in the cards for
you
no that was why she didn't support my
marriage
because i told her us getting married we
both knew we wouldn't have kids and she
said that
i needed to give her grandkids and we
there you go see
you're just a prop for her and i
absolutely hate to be the one to tell
you that you probably already know that
but um her relationship with you
is all about her and that's not how moms
are supposed to
treat their daughters that's not how
dads are supposed to treat their sons
and all the inner mixing of that as well
and that sucks for you um
so the sooner you can let that go the
better if she ever does reach out to you
again
i think the hospitable and kind thing to
do is to speak to her
to be nice um if you want to send her
christmas cards every year you want to
write her a letter every few months i
think that's
that's that's noble right and
there's distance there and you may want
to keep her up that that will give you
peace of mind
because here's what i know about you and
just talking to you for 10 minutes
you're a good person chris
you're somebody who'll go pick up their
dad and make a room in their home for
him
you're somebody who looks for signs on
how to care for people
you're somebody who is always looking
for reconciliation and
that's that's i mean if everybody lived
like that that'd be incredible
the sucky part about people who look for
reconciliation all the time
find out eventually that not everybody's
searching for that and
um for folks like who search for
reconciliation
it's a painful life it's the right life
and it's good
but it's painful because it's not always
reciprocated your mom cashed out
whether she meant to whether she does it
on purpose whether it's been years and
years
of negative thinking um but all the way
back to when she would bring you in on
her affairs
to put that on a kid is it's just wrong
it's absolutely wrong to put that on a
child
hey look what i'm doing to your dad look
what i'm doing to your dad
you can't marry the guy that you love
because i'm not gonna get what i want
out of your relationship
it's ridiculous and chris i'm sorry that
your mom treated you that way
you deserved better you did
my hope is that one day she has an
awakening and calls you
and rekindles that relationship but
chris that's not going to be yours to
rekindle
it might be yours to receive someday but
not rekindle
oh chris we'll be thinking about you if
you do um get a note from her
if y'all do reconnect please give me a
call i love hearing stories of
reconciliation and connection
and um i love it when moms find their
daughters
and all the moms listening to this
your daughter's life is not about
fulfillment of your fantasies
dads your son's life is not about
the the world you didn't have
your son's little league game is not
about you reclaiming your old
performance
mom your sons are not marrying you
dad's your daughters are not your
property
they're on loan and you need to love
them and
teach them and instruct them and hold
them accountable
and empower them and teach them
wonder and excitement and joy
but their lives are not for you
they're not for you
sorry chris all right let's go to jason
in virginia beach virginia jason what's
up
hey there dr delaney how are you doing
i'm all right my man how we doing
great thank you for taking my call thank
you for calling brother what's going on
for sure yeah so um i'm i'm about to
move to a new city that's roughly three
hours
two or three hours away uh and while i'm
excited about starting a new job and
going to a new place and moving out of
my parents house for the first time away
from my hometown
i'm also nervous about it and
basically i'm just looking for advice on
you know how to kind of reestablish
community friendships stuff like that uh
basically i'm moving away to start a new
job how old are you man
i'm 27. what yeah
jason you're 27 asking me how to move
out of your mom's house
come on man yeah come on
man why are you still living at your
mom's house at 27
well so basically i had a full-time job
uh
but i didn't really feel comfortable
moving in with roommates or um
things like that why not why not why not
well i think i think it was just because
of the security of it in a way
uh that i've enjoyed and
um so hey we gotta drill down in this
man i'm sorry to interrupt you
so now you're dead you had a full-time
job you're doing grown-up things
but you liked the security of your mom's
house
to the point that you didn't want to
have roommates you didn't want to
split the rent you didn't even want to
have your own apartment so when you say
you liked the security of your mom's
house is that warm meals does she tuck
you in
did she sing to you at night like what
what do you mean you like the security
no i think it was just a thing of like i
i feel like i have trust issues with
other folks
and um where does that come from
in all honesty i i feel like i
don't necessarily know per se um
yeah um
is your mom does your mom love having
you at home
she does yeah is your dad there too
uh he is yeah what is he does he love
having you live at home
as an almost 30 year old man or is he
just mudder around the house
just shuffling his feet in his slippers
just going oh
that boy that boy or does he just kind
of kind of the ladder
kind of the ladder yeah okay and
was your mom somebody who was overly
involved in your life is this
new yeah i mean i would say my mom and i
were
definitely closer than me and my dad for
sure
so i mean if you're almost 30 just now
moving out for the first time
yeah i mean i guess i can see that this
is going to be weird for you
um yeah i mean i'm excited about it it's
just i'm nervous about it to a whole new
level
you know what what what led you to
finally
cut the umbilical cord and take a job
three hours away
yeah um well you know it's one of those
things where i felt like when i woke up
on my birthday this past year
i just realized i didn't want to be
seven years old
yeah like i i don't want to be living at
my parents house forever you know
especially when i have like friends of
mine that have moved on with their lives
and like i just i didn't want to be that
guy you know
okay so people call my show for a hard
truth brother so i'm just telling you
you super are that guy you already are
okay now you can work to become on that
guy but right now
i am just telling you you are that guy
yeah so until you've lived in another
city
um or in another house in another
one-bedroom apartment for a year
you're that guy okay yeah and so
you woke up one day you're on your 27th
birthday and you just had this like what
am i doing
and you started applying for jobs you
got a job three hours away
what field do you work in so i work in
uh process management i don't even know
what that means but it sounds like you
manage
processes so that's good and you're
going three hours away
have you already got an apartment you
already got a house yeah
uh actually uh what's funny is i
actually i just moved
the other day yeah oh so you're here all
by yourself
and your big boy house yeah uh yeah i've
i've hit the ground here so
okay so jason like have you been
sleeping and i'm not making
i'm not making fun i'm being serious
have you been sleeping
yeah so um i i feel like i've been
sleeping well
um i think it's one of those things
where it's like the excitement of it has
kind of hit
but also it's just one of those things
where i
i i'm nervous about you know rebuilding
community with friends that i know here
and stuff like that
so yeah so um
i'm gonna do two different things here
okay number one
okay um i've had my fun at your expense
right and it sounds like you're
good-natured and you get it right that
you're 27 and we're still living with
your mom
you even woke up one day and you're like
dude what am i doing okay so
yeah now everyone listening to this
whether they are mowing the lawn walking
through target somewhere
they are doing whatever it is they're
doing and
they are smiling and or laughing that
there's a guy who's 27 who just moved
out of his mommy's house for the first
time
so there's that okay and then there's
also
part two here which is the very real
fear and nervousness and
so i want to tell you i'm high-fiving
you i'm proud of you for making this
jump
okay and i don't want to minimize the
fact that it is weird it is hard
okay so here's a couple of things that i
had to do recently now i didn't move out
of my mom's house
i i've haven't lived with my parents for
a long time for a couple of decades
but i did leave this
a city i'd been in for years and years
and years and i
left friends that i met with every week
for
years and i left places where i knew the
police officers by name i knew city
leaders by name i knew
where the plumber's by name right i knew
all i had a community there
and here's what i had to do i had to be
hyper
hyper intentional about applying
the the true research to my life okay so
here's what the research says jason
all right loneliness will kill you
literally okay um
eating unhealthy will kill you
not moving and not not moving your body
not exercising not
sleeping those things will kill you okay
all of that starts with
intentionality you have to put yourself
in a situation where you are
hyper intentional about finding friends
and connection and community that could
be through a local church that could be
through
groups with work that could be through
um going up to the ymca and playing
pickup basketball games there's few
people on earth worse at basketball than
me
but just put yourself in a situation
where you're going to be around other
people
and here's the thing i need you to
remember i want you to
write this down relationships start with
risk and not with certainty so there is
a 100
chance you're going to ask someone to go
hang out and they're going to blow you
off
and that doesn't mean that you're an
idiot that doesn't mean you're a failure
that means you're just learning
that means that they don't want to hang
out with you cool and move on to the
next and on to the next and on to the
next
relationships start with risk it's
always worth it even if you're on the
other end of the
the negative side of risk right and so
you're going to be hyper intentional
about making community
and that's going to be you saying weird
things like hey man will you be my
friend
and laughing about it um hey man let's
go hang out
i want to come and hang out at my house
i'll pick up the tab
and it's going to be especially hard
during covid
right because some some folks have
different um abilities to hang out
not hang out can we do it outside inside
heading into winter is going to be tough
you're going to just be hyper
intentional
and then you're going to be hyper
intentional about taking care of your
your mental health which means you're
going to have to move you're gonna have
to eat right you're gonna have to
exercise you're gonna you have to do all
those things
that let you have a good night's sleep
that let you know that you're okay
and then here's um the last thing i
would challenge you on
i would be very intentional about not
calling
and or texting my mom every day
yeah i want you to set a weaning off
schedule
okay where you say i'm gonna reach out
i'm gonna call once a week and that's
gonna push you to develop relationships
in other places
and here's here's something else it's
going to push your mom to have to
develop some different support networks
too
because she's probably leaned on you a
long time
for her own good she's probably
giving you meals way past when she
should have and she's probably
encouraged you just to stay on at home
way
longer than she should have because it
felt
it it satisfied a need in her and you're
gonna have to let her go develop
relationships too
and expect her to call you it crying i
miss you
i wish you would just come home that's
not on you
that's for her to deal with okay your
responsibility
is not making sure that she has friends
and not making sure that her relational
needs are met that's her job
okay your job is to nobly respect your
mom
um honor her care for her but not to
make sure that um she doesn't cry
that she doesn't um that her relational
needs are met i've said that over and
over but
um so have you reached out to somebody
have you hung out with anybody since you
landed in your new town
uh no i haven't okay that's your goal
for this week
okay got it yeah absolutely that's your
goal for this week is to find somebody
to have lunch with to hang out with
talk to them say hi um
i i don't know i don't i don't even know
what you're allowed to do and whatever
town you're in
the things are different all over the
country but some places got movie
theaters that are open people are going
to concerts and comedy shows and
other places it's like um
siberia right you just can't move you
just stay in your house all day and just
walk circles around your couch and so
i don't know what community you're in
but your job this week is to make
connection with somebody
some group of people would probably even
better and
um to start making connection there
have a backup system
that's not your mom have a backup system
that's not
your old bedroom in your old house it's
time for you to go i'm proud of you for
making this call even though i'm going
to poke at you because you're 27.
i'm proud of you for waking up and
realizing oh my gosh i don't want to be
a guy who's at 30 live in his mom's
house
it's a big move man and um get some
community take care of yourself
all right let's go to whitney in atlanta
georgia whitney
good morning how are we doing good how
are you
thanks for having me i'm good thank you
so much for calling
so what's up so i am a stay-at-home mom
of four amazing little boys my oldest is
seven and my youngest is 19 months
can we just stop for a second can we
stop brazilian whoa
that's a lot that is a lot which
is so fun especially during covet good
for you
oh you're a hero all right so how can i
help
um so my husband attempted suicide in
september
oh my gosh i'm so sorry yeah thank you
um
it was extremely violent okay when the
kids and i were home
and you know i'm confused and angry
and so my main question is how can i
remain
supportive through my confusion and my
anger and to even take it further
how could i ever trust him again or
trust myself with him again
[Music]
wow that's a lot yeah was it out of the
blue has he been showing signs of
depression for
a long time walk me through what led up
to this
okay so um i mean
for me initially before i went and did
some digging as you may understand i was
trying to look for my why
yeah um but for me it looked like a
really
hard quick downward spiral okay but i'm
starting to understand that this must
have been
a longer path for him right a longer
path of
depression anxiety and probably sleep
deprivation
really um but he he never seemed to be
satisfied with where he was in his
career
and he never got the success that we had
both hoped for
so about a little over three years ago
he started his own business
and in january of last year actually
this year
this past january he got what i would
call his big break
we were finally financially comfortable
able to do the things that we wanted and
something happened at work
um starting like at the end of june i
don't really know the details of it all
but i'm trying to figure that out
hopefully it comes out more as he goes
through
his recovery but um i started seeing
him change and he and towards the end in
september he's he was like a walking
zombie a shell of himself
he wasn't sleeping he was super paranoid
and
i saw this and i tried to get him help
um i actually he ended up going to
um an inpatient hospital and they
released him in three days they really
just kind of threw medication at him
and released them and that was it
and that was when he was released he was
released on monday of labor day
that was labor day um that whole week he
i could tell
nothing had changed and he he was still
in a really bad place so
i had set up an outpatient program for
him to start monday september 14th and
on the 13th
is when it happened okay
and when you say he survived is he got
all his faculties
is he is he recovered physically
he was in the hospital for a month and
he still is whispering
only a whisper we don't know if he'll
ever speak normally again
okay um but i mean physically he's
he's recovering yeah he's now i actually
you know moved mountains to get him to a
facility in florida
because the georgia mental health was a
little tough um i really wanted a whole
program that could
he could be at for a while and really
figure out what was going on
okay so he's he's getting the help he
needs but and i want to be supportive
and i want him to get healthy he's a
good dad he's a good person there's not
one person that will
ever say anything bad about him so this
is very
shocking yeah um
so before we get into your heart on this
deal
what did your boys see
did they experience this trauma too
firsthand are they just
in the room obviously when you were
experiencing this and the flashing
lights and all that
yeah so they i mean i'm so thankful they
were outside we were all
we were supposed to go to the pool so i
was getting them ready to go to the pool
outside and i was actually having his
parents come
and sit with him because i saw something
kind of switch in him and suddenly he
didn't want to go to the pool
um and actually i should probably tell
you that
he he started cutting himself
two weeks prior to this happening and
what switched in him was when he changed
into his bathing suit i saw more cuts on
his leg
and i kind of was like oh my god what
what are you when did you do that and
some i saw something switch in him
i called his parents and i was like well
now i have to take
the kids to the pool they're so excited
they've been waiting to go can you sit
with him
and he only went inside for a minute to
put you know a toy on the counter
and the kids were still in the garage
outside
and it's the second that door shut i was
like oh my gosh
he's he's alone i i asked my son to go
scream for daddy hey come outside come
outside and when he said he wasn't
answering
yeah i just told my oldest day with the
stay with them don't move stay in the
driveway and i ran inside
and broke down a locked bathroom door to
find him
so i want to um start walking so again
they didn't they didn't see anything
they only saw the
you know the emergency cars they saw the
police cars the fire engines
so that's all they saw so that's a lot
and if you haven't already they need to
have somebody that they can talk to a
registered play therapist who knows what
they're doing
who can slowly integrate trauma into
their life
and they will this will play back
in different ways differently with each
one of those boys but i would strongly
recommend you've got somebody in that
community
a good play therapist that can walk
through that with them
and they pick up way way way more than
you think they do
and the damaging thing for kids
is they pick up that tension they pick
up those flashing lights they pick up
mommies crying they pick up mommy's
pacing back and forth all of the adults
all the casseroles showing up
and they register that they had
something to do with that
and that manifests itself in all sorts
of
ping-pong ways all throughout their life
and so we call it trauma integration it
is a part of their life
and they 100 can heal from it and in
fact they can heal from it in ways that
make them
super resilient and a gift to anyone who
runs into them for the rest of their
life
but it's got to be appropriately
integrated otherwise it will come out in
all sorts of
wild ways and so you didn't call me for
advice on them but my head always
always goes to the children first okay
they picked way more of this up than you
probably think they did and you've been
doing the lord's work trying to shield
them from this and protect them from
this
um but they are able to at whatever
cellular level
put together mommy screaming and blood
and flashing lights and daddy's not home
and
that will they will do an algorithm in
their head that just doesn't add up
right and that they are the
at the other end of that equal sign and
so find a play therapist for them
and then for you um i don't know if
anyone's told you this and i hope they
have but if they haven't
you saw something that nobody is
supposed to see and i'm sorry
thanks i'm working with someone i'm not
good you are not supposed to see that
and i'm sorry that you did
and i've seen too much of that and i
wasn't supposed to see it
and i'm proud of you for doing the hard
work of going to see somebody
so here's a couple of things just to
wrap your head around and again
hopefully people have told you this and
so i'm telling you this
and the listener here um
suicide's not something that is done by
cowardly folks
right and it's not something that
somebody does
to on a whim generally
the fact that you saw those cuts um
suggest two things right thomas joyner
is dr joyner is one of the
most extraordinary suicidologists they
call him in the country
and he has a couple of prongs for
how people can finally get to this place
where they believe
the world is better off without them and
that they are hurting so bad that this
is the only solution right
and that is number one this idea that
they are lonely
and not only are they lonely but their
presence is a burden to other people
and this idea that they can actually do
it and so often
cutting isn't a big deal and it usually
shocks people when i say that
but there is evidence to where sometimes
cutting is people practicing
the ability to hurt themselves they are
leaning into this because that's a
really
difficult thing for for the human body
to do to itself right
um and i want you to know that it wasn't
your fault and in fact he's alive
because of you right
so how do you trust him again it's going
to be a long road
and i wish there was an easy answer to
that but there's not going to be
it's going to be hard for you to trust
him it's going to be hard for you to
leave
his and your kids with him
it's going to be hard to fully lean up
against that guy
who's been fighting and clawing for his
family for all these years
and the good dad of your boys it's going
to be hard
and it's gonna be something i want you
to keep this word in your head it's
gonna be something that you're gonna
have to practice
you're gonna have to practice trusting
it's not something that's just gonna
come back magically when
he gets out of
his program and he's medically healed
and he is at least safe enough where he
can go back in
be at home then the next step is going
to be y'all going to
a great marriage therapist with some
trauma background
and you all are going to have to rebuild
your relationship
from scratch yeah
and you may have heard me say this on
this show
often this is an analogy we use with
couples who've experienced infidelity
somebody cheats on somebody
but it applies here too and that is
your old relationship is now gone
it's gonna be on different footing and
so if you think about
they could never go back and get all of
the glass and dust
and steel and roofing tiles
that was the world trade center and get
all that dust
back and rebuild those with those
original parts what they had to do is
excavate the entire thing
and then they put out a bid for new
architectural drawings and they built
something that is stronger
it's able to withhold more and for some
it's a beacon of hope that will resound
in them forever
and so what you're going to have to do
is be committed to building something
new
not trying to duct tape and piece
together what y'all had because what you
had
is is now been disrupted right
right and so this is the journey you're
on and it's going to be
real normal for you to be angry to be
lonely
it's going to be normal for you to be
super frustrated just because you're
going to do bedtime by yourself with
those four boys
it's gonna that all that stuff's normal
and you're gonna have to be real real
graceful
with yourself besides having somebody
that you're working with the therapist
you're working with do you have friends
in your community that you can be honest
honest and vulnerable with who
who are walking with you i do yeah i'm
lucky
okay really lucky well you may be lucky
but you may have cultivated it too right
for just a time such as this
right right right so
are you in it for the long haul are you
in it too
i mean do you have it in you to to
rebuild this thing
i don't know yet okay i feel like i'm in
an in-between
stage and i am supportive and i my goal
my first goal for him is to
for him to get healthy my second goal
would for
him to financially provide for his kids
again
because we have to put food on the table
and his job is gone
so i'm having not only to deal with the
kids but in sports and homework
you know but finances all on my own and
then it would be you know he's got to be
a dad again to these boys
and then it would be the marriage for me
i mean i i almost imagine that
we need to co-parent for a while first
because i just don't like
right now and i don't know how i'm gonna
feel six months from now but right now
i can't imagine him walking into this
house and just
living here again why not because
i don't like i will start looking at the
kitchen knives and be like oh my god
they're out like oh my like i just don't
i don't trust them but but also when i'm
talking to him and there is a family
therapist
with that speaks with both of us every
monday
from this facility okay so i speak to
him and you know he hasn't really made
any progress yet and i know that
that it's a really long road and for me
i'm just looking for it to be faster but
i mean i so right now i just can't
imagine that he
is just going to be held like one day
he's going to be healthy right now i
can't see it
sure so i don't know every time i look
at a kitchen i have to cut vegetables i
think of him now that's right
and that's that goes back to you
shouldn't have seen what you saw
right and that's where your healing's
gonna have to be
um a high priority for you and
what i want to tell you is if you choose
to remain married to him
the way you just described the playback
will have to be inverted
meaning he can only do the work that
helps him be well
he has to be committed to being well he
has to be committed to
taking care of himself he's got to be
committed to
dealing with the darkness and the
depression and the burdensome
feelings he's got to deal with all that
but once he comes back
he can only and you can only move
forward with the co-parenting with the
honoring your kids and in ann
through connection right
and the other part of it is that when i
did look for
why he did this or what happened i found
out that he had been lying to me for
some time
sure um so it was it's almost like he
was living a double life
so if he can't let me in and he can't be
vulnerable with me and he can't how am i
going to help them like how is it
going to work i want you to do a real
important thing
okay and if you get nothing out of this
phone call i want you to do a real
important thing
how old's your oldest little boy seven
seven so your little boy
comes in at two a.m and says mommy i
don't feel good
and you're in a haze and you wake up and
you're like what honey and he says mommy
i don't feel
good and then he just barfs all over
your bed
that's gross it's super frustrating and
annoying
but you can't get mad at him because he
did the only thing he could do
in that moment that he came to his mom
the one safe place that he knows and
then his body was sick
and so right now i you're you're gonna
wear yourself
out moralizing what happened to your
husband
you've got to transition that thought to
my husband's sick
and if it helps you to to imagine he was
in a car wreck
if it happened if it helps you to
imagine he's got
some sort of cardiovascular disease or
something so be it
but your husband's sick
he didn't do this to get at you he
didn't do this
to ruin your life
no more than your seven-year-old son
wouldn't do that just so you'd have to
do extra laundry
okay your husband's sick he's not well
and when you get frustrated and when you
get angry
it's easy to go get inside of his head
and try to figure out why he did this
and why he didn't do this
but the reality is he made some bad
decisions on top of
some messy brain chemistry on top of
probably a bunch of
childhood trauma plus he didn't have the
tools to walk through it and reach
across that aisle to you and say help
he was sick right and so
you are simply going to weigh yourself
down carrying around your anger at him
it's normal but i'm just telling you
you're going to bury yourself he is off
in a facility somewhere it's not going
to help him
he's not going to quote unquote get any
message from your anger and your
frustration
okay and so what i want to ask you to do
today
is make a commitment whether you write
him an angry letter
whether you
write down my husband was sick on a
piece of paper
or put it on a brick and carry it around
for a little bit and then just set that
down
you carrying around just pissed off at
him
for ruining everything is understandable
but it's just
crushing you and that's not true it's
not crushing just you it's crushing your
kids too
and that's a non-fear an unfair
statement that i'm giving you but i just
want to give you the reality you're
hurting your kids too
put it down set it down
what you saw is unimaginable what you
are experiencing is unimaginable
what you are having to pivot and do
life was going one way in january and
all of a sudden it's going a totally
different direction
not by your hand but in your lap
put down your hatred and your anger and
your frustration at him
at your disbelief at him he's sick
continue to walk with people who love
you continue to walk forward with your
trauma therapist
continue to show up to those monday
family sessions and
lean in as best as you can and put the
anger and the hatred down
i would love it whitney if you would
call continue to call
every couple of weeks let us know how
you're doing let us know how the therapy
is going
and we will continue to think about you
and be
in prayer for you as you walk this
journey
it's gonna be a long journey and the
the least amount of baggage you've got
carrying with you the better
so as we wrap up today um
we're gonna go to this song we're gonna
go to the one of my favorite songs
ever and i know i say that a lot and
this time i'm actually being serious
um it's off the i and love and you
record
it's a song by the avat brothers it's
called a head full of doubt and a road
full of promise
and it goes like this there's a darkness
upon me that's flooded in light
and in the fine print they tell me
what's wrong and what's right and it
comes in black and it comes in white
and i'm frightened by those that don't
see it when nothing is
owed or deserved or expected and your
life doesn't change by the man that's
elected
and you're loved by someone you're never
rejected decide what to be and go be it
there was a dream and one day i could
see it like a bird in a cage i broke in
and demanded that somebody free it
and there was a kid with a head full of
doubt
so i'll scream till i die and the last
of those bad thoughts are finally out
there was a dream and one day i could
see it like a bird in a cage i broke in
and demanded that somebody free it
and there was a kid with a head full of
doubt
[Music]
so i'll scream till i die and the last
of those bad thoughts are finally out
[Music]
this is the dr john de lumie show